und höre mensch es wort geschrieben
wer sich gegen gott versündigt dem
drohen höllenqualen
und siehe mensch noch immer gilt sündige
laster stehen sogar manchem verbrechen
alte tugenden neue fälle heute habgier
grüßt sie mit mir ganz herzlich die
präsidentin des
[Applaus]
es ist wirklich eine frechheit wenn wir
daher kommen und meinen von diesem
riesigen kuchen da können wir ja alle
ein stück haben weil wir kommen wenn
nein was er könnte herauskommen was ihr
die letzten 50 jahren wir uns geblieben
habt traumrenditen für kleinanleger
das verspricht die european kings club
präsidentin damara bertges mitte der
90er jahre
[Applaus]
tausende von schweizern investieren in
den european kings club kurz genannt
[Applaus]
doch der ehc ist ein schneeballsystem
nach drei jahren bricht alles zusammen
statt traumgewinne riesenverluste
[Musik]
es ist eine geschichte wie aus der bibel
als ob gott zeigen wollte dass habgier
schlecht ist es ist die geschichte einer
milliarden-pleite derzeitige gar wurden
auch in serie
das macht auf das 1 liter hätten an der
seite des oder dummheit machen sie war
aber die 120 baubehörde alte lied von 67
und einem schloss gekommen
es ist so das lied natürlich blind
werden unter tel
unter dem ruf vom streben nach einem
schneller geht das märchen vom schnellen
geld beginnt mitte der 90er jahre
dieser 20 jährige maurer lässt sich
damals vom fernsehen porträtieren statt
auf dem bau arbeitet er jetzt für den
european kings club kurz apps genannt
er verkauft jene traum papiere des ekz
die sagenhaft reich machen sollen lätta
heißen sie
[Musik]
wer einen letter für 1400 franken kauft
erhält nach kurzer zeit 2400 franken
zurück ein gewinn von 70 prozent
angeblich erreicht weil der ehc das geld
weltweit geschickt investiert der
ehemalige maurer auf kunden tour viele
der letter verkäufer sind bergbauern im
urner schächental im volksmund damals
zum letter valium benannt
[Applaus]
und das ist gut so
[Musik]
es ist
damals mitte der 90er jahre einer der
vielen auftritte von damara bertges
[Applaus]
lautlos
[Musik]
[Applaus]
15 jahre später
wir treffen damara bertges in einer
deutschen kleinstadt erstmals nach dem
zusammenbruch des ekz gibt sie auskunft
sie erzählt wie sie auf die idee mit der
traumrendite kam
ich habe gerne ihre bilanzen gelesen und
irgendwann habe ich mir mal wieder so
eine bilanz geholt in einer bank und in
dieser bilanz steckte eine beilage und
da bot damals eine japanische bank wenn
ich mich richtig erinnere stand die
damals an achter stelle der welt banken
ein investitions angebot an bei dem eine
durchschnittliche rendite von um die 80
prozent irgendwie ausgewiesen war über
67 jahre
allerdings hat die sache einen haken es
war eine mindesteinlage von 10 millionen
dollar notwendig ihr kompagnon war hans
günter stolz der ehemalige arzt
schwachholz und die hausfrau bertges
beginnen 1992 kleinanleger anzusprechen
auch schwachholz gibt erstmals vor der
kamera auskunft mit ein paar euro oder
ein paar dem oder paar schweizer franken
können sie nicht viel anfangen
man muss also schon größere summe
zusammenbekommen um die dann auch
sinnvoll investieren zu können
also war der grundgedanke war eben
entsprechend erst mal geld einsammeln
möglichst schnell möglichst viel war die
idee mich hat diese geschichte von
anfang an fasziniert und zwar ganz
einfach dieses 1000 mal 1000 macht macht
auch eine million durch diesen prospekt
das ist mir klar geworden dass man über
sehr viel oder viel geld ich was sie
jetzt immer technisch definiert zehn
millionen dollar mit sehr viel geld das
man da andere geschäfte machen könnte
und andere sachen machen könnte die man
mit 1000 mark nicht machen kann und dann
hat man überlegt wie könnte das aussehen
wie könnte man das gestalten wie könnte
das ablaufen was könnte man den für
namen geben und so weiter
und da ist halt in diesen
diskussionsrunden hat dann irgendjemand
hat dann plötzlich mal den namen kannten
kings knapp und klar und ging es klappt
haben wir ja das ist ja später den
european und dieses dieses system mit
dem letter das heißt also man zahlt 12
100 d-mark +200 gebühren für einen so
genannten letter oder äquivalent halt
schweizer franken und man bekommt dann
zwölf auszahlungen a 200 zurück das
heißt also hat dann nach 14 monaten hat
man also dann 70 prozent gewinn
sozusagen miteinander 70 prozent gewinn
angeblich möglich dank geschickter
investition
doch in wahrheit ein schneeballsystem
die neuen anleger bezahlen den alten die
rendite früher oder später bricht es
zusammen
doch in der ländlichen innerschweiz
wurde dass viele nicht wahrhaben
es lockt das schnelle geld ich möchte
sagen dass das eine absolut grandiose
sache ist und dass sich viele menschen
für etwas sehr gutes einsätzen steht in
unsere social weil ich so toll
so etwas wird es nie mehr geben da steht
total hinter der sache hinter der sehr
guten sache und da ist jedes mittel
legal damit ich dabei sein kann
habgier versetzt lüth natürlich eine
stimmige ihres bewusst so ziemlich der
wunsch und das streben nach dem
schnellen geld das führt dazu dass man
sich immer groß überlege gemacht sondern
dass man auf wunsch schnell profitieren
hallo herzlich willkommen an bord
ich freue mich dass sie nicht begleiten
wollte auf unserem blog egert sie 31 7
93 in eine welt der fantasie
ein kings club video von damals
originator technos ist der name des
volkes das überwiegend diesem planeten
gewohnt der lebensinhalt der technos ist
in zwei worten zu beschreiben
sie müssen arbeiten und konsumieren so
sichern sie das paradiesische dasein der
karate die piraten haben alles unter
kontrolle und genießen die früchte der
arbeit anderer
und das geht lange gut zu lange dann
befreit der kings klappt mit dem letter
zauberstab die unterdrückten technos
[Musik]
mit den kings corp ist es nicht nur um
investitionen um rationale
wirtschaftliche überlegungen gegangen
sondern es ist sehr starkes
gemeinschaftsgefühl gang um das gefühl
dass man als einfacher bürger auch an
teilhabe am wirtschaftlichen fortschritt
und das hat mich gestärkt worden durch
vereinsveranstaltungen sie hat sich nur
noch unter sich seien betroffen und hat
sich immer wieder mehr bestärkt dass das
richtig ist und dass das system
funktioniert und das ist typisch für
sechs strukturen wo man sich abschottet
und wo man erinnere ideologie immer mehr
folgt
[Applaus]
auf der stelle wo nicht unter diesen
verdammten nächste und über 20.000
schweizerinnen und schweizer investieren
geld in klings klar
frau berg ist hat das sehr gut genutzt
der freiheitsdrang von der
innerschweizer sozusagen sie hat die
ideologie damit mit dem schweizerischen
ideal verbunden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie hat das aufrauen eine gemischt mit
der kritik der banken und finanzplatz
wofür sich selber nur profit
erwirtschaftet lina lüth links liegt
laut sie haben also bis ganz interessant
gemacht seinem kapitalismuskritik
betrieb aber sie haben wäre eigentlich
der kapitalismus für die freenet wie
früher wo dann
dadurch könnte die beiden ganz gut die
soziale position aufstiege einer der
treusten anhänger von damals war dieser
mann heute will er nichts mehr sagen
damals aber gewährte er interview an
interview auf hochdeutsch zb für das
welche publikum
dafür ist die rütliwiese darf diese
rütliwiese da habe ich vor 700 fünf
jahren unsere alten eidgenossen einen
schwur abgelegt in diesen 700 fünf
jahren dies eigentlich gar nichts
verändert wurden die alten eidgenossen
haben gekämpft gegen unterdrückung gegen
völpke gemacht habe
und das ist eigentlich heute noch genau
das gleiche nur ein unterschied
existiert diese folglich sind nicht mehr
in richtungen
sie sind haben das gekleidet aber die
unterdrückung ist genau die beiden
gewinnen
[Musik]
der feind von uns ist das großkapital
das sind die punkte sind die banken das
sind die versicherungen
wir sind sand im getriebe und da stört
in diesem system
dieses system ist aufgebaut wurden von
den reichen leuten von den fakten und
wenn jemand herkommt und sand in dieses
getriebe streit dann stört das in der
kings club werbung stellten sich
schweizer top blätter verkäufer so vor
was möchten sie den ehc mitgliedern
sagen freiheit selbständigkeit
unabhängigkeit menschen für menschen
lieber für menschen vertrauen
die kings klappt fahne damals auf einem
roller geschäftshaus der inhaber war
einer der wichtigsten schweizer kings
club direktoren realistisch muss eine
beziehung zu haben
[Applaus]
die meisten betriebe hat gesehen dass in
alle welt natürlich dass über gebraucht
und das ist ja wieder erschien sondern
die welt existiert und machen damit
hätten viele lücken die sich im umfeld
viel mitgemacht was natürlich gold dazu
bietet oder aber eine speziell verwendet
und verwies sie überzeugt wenn nicht war
dann durch das nicht machen tut es nicht
machen
kein schneeballsystem sondern seriöse
investitionen betont die spitze immer
wieder
wir wissen doch ganz genau dass ihr ganz
genau ist dass wir sehr wohl investieren
und nicht wie immer behauptet nicht
investieren um ein schneeballsystem war
das kind klappt zentrum in deutschland
millionen werden hier durchgeschleust
weiter transportiert und angeblich
investiert wo will der kings club nicht
verraten angeblich ein
geschäftsgeheimnis hunderttausend
mitglieder hat der club inzwischen
europaweit und weil die rendite noch
regelmäßig ausbezahlt wird glauben immer
mehr an das wunder ungefähr zwei jahren
sich plötzlich eine eigendynamik
entwickelt hat so dass das hat einen
fast weg gerissen war geradezu
unglaublich wie wie das plötzlich ja wie
es ein davon getragen hat es war
praktisch die beine wie bei einer lawine
plötzlich kam neutronen ende immer mehr
mitglieder immer mehr geld wir wussten
teilweise schon kaum noch wie man immer
den der geldströme herr werden sollte
da muss ich wirklich sagen es ist
fantastisch es ist fantastisch was wir
bisher erreicht haben wir alle gemeinsam
unsere haben und seien wir werden in
zukunft auch die gangs erreichen
[Applaus]
wichtig für uns
der fall kings club ist einmalig
europäischer geschichte sondern großer
fall von einem schneeball system hatte
zeichnet sich durch internationalität
als grenzüberschreitend geahndet wurde
und es ist so nach der glaubensfrage
wurde man hat einen führer werkes
anvertraut das ist identifikationsfigur
xxi und das hat dazu geführt dass sie
die innerschweizer im kanton uri und im
kanton glarus jederzeit gewachsen
jedes system investiert hat
[Musik]
die lüfterlose style zu groß sind wie
möglich sie sind sie an der grammer kam
mit einer reisezeit aber stark verändert
und das hat einen grauen oder das werk
tatsächlich videoschnitt oder das große
geld danach haben wir das gefühl könnte
nach einem rätsel
[Musik]
ich glaube das ist für die meisten shows
ereignis sieht als saison events
stattfinden oder gorbatschow roche und
abb
meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen michael gorbatschow
[Applaus]
im namen aller mitglieder des european
kings club überreichen wir in dieser
urkunde als ehrenmitglied des european
kings club
ich hoffe dadurch gezeigt dass wir alles
aber auch wirklich alles woran wir fest
glauben auch in die tat umsetzen können
seid ihr damit wir einer meinung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenige monate später ist alles zu ende
ich habe es aus vollem herzen und mit
voller überzeugung getan
es ist schief gegangen
und weil es schiefgegangen nur ist bin
ich schuldig bin verurteilt worden bin
zu recht verurteilt worden aber nicht
weil ich schuldig wer wissentlich einen
gedruckt zu begangen zu haben sondern
ganz einfach weil ich bereit war diese
verantwortung zu übernehmen wenn ich als
präsidentin auf die bühne zu stellen
dinge zu sagen dinge zu versprechen
und es ist nicht gut gegangen völlig
unabhängig davon ob das jetzt meine
schuld war das gut gegangen ist oder
nicht war ich einer der köpfe davon und
muss entsprechend die verantwortung
annehmen und das habe ich getan und aus
diesem grund bin ich natürlich schuldig
der zusammenbruch beginnt mitte 1994 die
justiz verhaftete zahlreiche schweizer
führungsmitglieder wegen betrugverdachts
und weil sie ohne banklizenz geld
einsammeln
die anhänger protestieren zuerst
friedlich dann militanter sie fürchten
um ihre investition
[Applaus]
und das ist für sie daher nicht der
untersuchungshaft daneben ist krank ist
und da hält sie sich mit einer
demonstration als entsprechend weiter
druck machen dass man die vielen
[Musik]
weil ich habe für die liste blendet sie
vor der damalige sieht das so hat eine
kölner klinik und abgabenpolitik
bausteins jahren habe ich habe ein paar
hundert und entwickelt da habe ich mich
aber nie bedroht gefühlt das tier bis
machthaber und einfach zu fall brachte
half das ist doch dumm was du machst das
volk hier lohnt sich doch das wort die
sachen downloaden
daher ist es okay dass man eigentlich
polizei schoss übers wochenende kaum
aushält mehr beobachter der familie
begleitet teil bis hin zur begleitet von
mir einfach nicht wüssten was haben
diese mitgliedern aus aktuellem anlass
möchte ich mich heute wieder an sie
könnten sie alle wissen dass bereits
seit vielen monaten gegen den klub und
seine mitglieder agitiert wird aber
hätte ja und nein ich gehöre ein ekz
video zeigt einen protest vor einem
berner gefängnis
[Musik]
wir warten auf dich da der spanier bei
mittlerweile stoppen die rendite
zahlungen der grund seien die
verhaftungen beruhigt die ekd spitze
die gelder seien gewinnbringend
investiert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kaufungen das ordnen lassen klaus
zumwinkel
der letzte auftritt nahe der schweizer
grenze damara bertges meidet die schweiz
aus angst vor einer verhaftung
es wird schwer die nächste zeit das gebe
ich zu aber wir werden mittel und
möglichkeiten finden und wie gesagt auch
die schweiz hat ihre grenzen und die
sequenzen kann man über schreiben
wer sein
[Musik]
und richter
so
hahahaha
kurz darauf für tamara bertges angeklagt
wegen betrugs und unerlaubter bank
tätigkeit der jurist gerhard walter
erhält den auftrag nach den angeblichen
investitionen zu suchen
doch er findet fast nichts mehr der
grund liegt darin dass also die oberste
spitze frau bleibt es unter sprach
tolles jahr händeringend
vermögensanlagen gesucht haben wo sie
eingesammelte geld gewinnbringend
anlegen konnten die gewinnbringenden
anlage bestand darin dass sie im grunde
genommen auf weitere gegner getroffen
sind mit denen in kontakt kamen die ihn
im grunde genommen dieses geld
abgenommen haben
vor dem gericht wollte am arlberg es
damals keine auskunft geben
jetzt spricht sie erstmals darüber wie
sie ohne abklärungen dubiosen personen
millionen anvertraute
ich meinte ihn gut zu kennen und da war
auch von anfang an meinem klub dabei ich
hätte niemals für möglich gehalten dass
er mir jemanden ins haus bringt
beziehungsweise mich jemandem vorstellt
jemanden mit einem projekt zu mir bringt
der uns dann um satte 27 millionen rand
leider war es aber so dass weder ich
noch die frau werkes von von der
ausbildung her jemals etwas damit zu tun
hatten
das heißt wir haben zwar händeringend
fachleute gesucht also investmentberater
und entsprechende andere leute die sich
damit auskennen haben aber leider keine
gefunden jedenfalls keine ehrlichen
allerdings haben sich doch eine ganze
reihe leute eingeschlichen die das ganze
system ehc dann zu ihrem eigenen vorteil
missbraucht haben und letztlich in die
eigene tasche gewirtschaftet haben und
teilweise ganz bewusst auch getäuscht
und hinters licht geführt haben mit
falschen rechnungen diversen anderen
geschichten auch weiter sind keine
fachleute für die anlage von geldern
wussten eigentlich waren völlig hilflos
diesem geschäftsvolumen was da an
gestimmt haben waren die völlig hilflos
ausgeliefert
dass argentinien projekt fing an dann
kommt noch jemand ein projekt war fürst
von liechtenstein oder ehemalige
finanzminister von österreich wissen sie
jemand wie ich der deckung der ehemalige
finanzminister von österreich hat seine
irgendeinem spiel das uns mal die
kleinigkeit von 10 millionen dollar
gekostet hat die dann irgendwie
verschwunden sind auch ab so dicke komme
ich nicht aber da kommt einer von dem
anderen
das ist wie sollte es beschreiben
anscheinend ist es so eine art europa
bei der seite auf die sprechen sich
anscheinend untereinander ab wem er dann
ganz toll abzocken kann wer das nicht
merkt oder so nach ist die halt zum
beispiel und aufgrund des mangelhaften
investments
und der mangelnden kontrolle in dem
bereich ist es natürlich leider dann zu
teilweise sehr herben und datenverlusten
gekommen münchen das dann auch im laufe
der zeit festgestellt
jeder der den irgendetwas positives
verkauft habe sei es im öko bereich sein
sonst wo hat geld bekommen
aber es kam ihm etwas zurück nichts von
70 prozent rendite nichts von wegen 1
prozent rendite versprochen worden war
keine chance gar keine chance
rund eine halbe milliarde franken sind
versichert 60.000 kleinanleger verloren
ihr geld es ist heute ein wissen für
mich mit dem ich mit dem schreiben muss
wenn ich mir nicht so leicht das ist
werde ich immer mit mir tragen
[Musik]
nach der festnahme sitzt am arlberg es
in basel im gefängnis lohn hof
in untersuchungshaft
[Musik]
die kings club anhänger demonstrieren
damals noch
[Musik]
und sie glauben immer noch die justiz
sei schuld dass kein geld mehr fließen
das gewohnte um dieses ziel er
gratuliere
obwohl sie im slider exit und zweitens
dankbar was sie muss bundestrainer
vermied und wieder nötig clubpräsidentin
dort inhaftiert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
später wird der maria bertges nach
deutschland ausgeliefert und dort
verurteilt
[Applaus]
die schweizer führungsmitglieder kommen
auch vor den richter sie erhalten milde
strafen
[Musik]
auf den ersten blick sind die urteil
sehr mild merkt was dafür schade
produziert worden sind hat man das
gefühl bedingt die freiheitsstrafe ist
eigentlich nicht auf masse aber gericht
hat sich das genau überlegen die elite
genauer anguckt und haben feststellt wir
sehen natürlich die erfahrung wie
gestraft die sind alle finanziell
ruiniert die hand selber investiert sie
haben selber das system glaubt sie sind
so nord wie ein betrogene betrüger und
darum hat man gefunden
bislang ist steckt das ist ja meistens
auch keine vorstrafen sie sind also
insofern normal integriert die person xi
und hat ihnen die bedingte
freiheitsstrafe chance geht es um sich
wieder stabilisieren
sprechen wollen sie nach dem
zusammenbruch nicht mehr
[Musik]
hans-günther schwachholz legt ein
geständnis ab er wird zu viereinhalb
jahren gefängnis verurteilt
war sicher die aufregendste zeit meines
lebens gewesen
und ich möchte wirklich nicht wissen
auch im nachhinein nicht wenn ich
gefragt werde
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich würde es
immer wieder tun schlicht und einfach
aus dem grund weil ich damals das gefühl
hatte eine aufgabe zu haben etwas
wichtiges zu tun und auch gebraucht zu
werden
der mara bertges wird weil sie die
zusammenarbeit mit der justiz verweigert
härter bestraft sie erhält acht jahre
gefängnis
[Musik]
und heute nach der haftentlassung um zu
zeigen wie ihr leben danach weiterging
zieht sie diese perücke an
ich hab mir das sehr genau überlegt ob
ich das interview mit ihnen machen
möchte oder nicht weil ich natürlich
wusste dass diese frage kommt und wenn
diese frage kommen würde würde ich mal
wieder vor der entscheidung stehen das
tue ich bin ich ich bin ich mich ich
möchte ich das tun aber bin ich ich
beantwortet sich von alleine man ist
immer derjenige der mann ist ob man es
zugibt oder nicht ich möchte einfach nur
ganz ich sein und das verantwortet
vielleicht die frage ich habe mein geld
in den letzten jahren als prostituierte
verdient
bis vor ein paar monaten ich hab das
nicht gerne getan was ist nicht ein job
wie jeder andere
aber es hat mich davor bewahrt
hinzugehen oder dem staat zur last zu
fallen
und für mich war es für mich sehr über
meine persönliche entscheidung
das ist auch die öffentlichkeit von
damals die das sieht und diejenigen die
mir damals vertraut haben die würden wir
das nicht vertragen wenn ich nicht getan
hat uns kommt dann auf eine andere art
aus und ich hätte mir nicht verziehen
es ist als ob gott zeigen wollte die
todsünde habgier wird hart bestraft
[Musik]